hi I'm Julia Fox and I played Julia and
uncut gems
I'm Jackie Gleason I'm on the
honeymooners I am idina menzel and I
played Tina we're about to take a
BuzzFeed test to see if we can pull off
a heist I think I will be able to
another YouTube walk we'll see about
[Music]
first things first why are you
committing this heist to help your
family to buy a new car to pay off your
debts to help a friend
I don't know to have more money heist
what heist that's good so I think heist
what heist because most criminals get
caught because they spoke to someone
about hmm that's very good but I'm not
gonna go with that one I'm gonna help my
goddamn family that's very admirable but
then you'll be too invested and you'll
get popped I would say to pack my debts
pick an iconic heist movie would you
guys see their Ocean's eleven and now
you see me
inception The Italian Job bad boys
Bonnie and Clyde I'm going with the
Italian Job because I am Italian I'm
smart I'm caught between Ocean's eleven
cuz all those guys are so hot yes and
Bonnie and Clyde just because it's funny
hot yeah what should I think
why don't you believe the hot guys okay
and I'll go and buy any guy so we're
both helping each other okay the object
is to be Julia pick a skill you wish you
had to help you pull off the perfect
crime computer hacking picking locks
manipulation pickpocketing stealth or
fist fighting I would like to be
stealthy I'm gonna go with straight-up
fist fighting mmm I said computer
hacking because I feel like everything
is done digitally these days that's good
what's your go-to Casino activity
blackjack poker roulette slot machine
craps the bar it's the bar I go with the
best dots in the house dad
craps I want to say craps I always want
to learn how to play craps it's so
confusing to me
I play blackjack so I'll go with that
look at this question everybody pick an
iconic Adam Sandler oh you're gonna be a
lot of fun I think how we Ratner from
uncut gems is off the table because that
didn't go so well for you what fine I
don't think any of these went so well
for you how dare you Big Daddy had Sonny
Koufax Davey stone ready crazy nice
Halle Ratner uncut gems Robbie Hart the
winning singer had begun more from the
incredible happy gilmore Henry Roth from
50 first dates this is a hard decision
for me I'm going with cartoon me because
I was definitely the best look I'm gonna
go with the wedding singer damn alright
then I'll go with what my son would pick
Big Daddy guys Thank You Nick weekend
song divide - I can't fit my face
starboy earned it and the hills I know
what the hell I'm gonna go I can't feel
my face
I'll give it up to the star boy finally
pick an uncut John diamond sapphire
amethyst Ruby Jade opal I want to say
amethyst good it's my birthstone but I
feel like it's the left but less
valuable one on here maybe just opal
because is that the one from the movie
movie I'll just pick Ruby cuz it sounds
really beautiful get caught don't worry
hit the big one diamond I'll never get
caught that's a guarantee
I might you got I got caught oh [ __ ] win
this it says congrats you made it and
made it out with the money and the gym
uncut of course don't go spending or
bending all your spoils in one place I
never do
alas you got not everyone is meant to
make it but look at it this way you can
always try again
it is nice look at the damn picture is
so charming I think I look just right
[Music]
[Music]